The entire Foundation was in turmoil; researchers
were getting into heated fistfights with security
officers, who in turn were retaliating in
fits of unbridled, animalistic rage. The
facility had erupted into such a frenzy, with
chairs being hurled across testing chambers,
and armories raided for weapons to escalate
the brawl into a far deadlier incident.
Tables were overturned and used as cover as the
Foundation’s own staff turned on each other,
and before long, an all-out war had erupted. But
this wasn’t a battle of one side versus another,
no this was a wild and rampant free for all.
Everyone was out to get everyone else, viewing
their own colleagues as mortal enemies. And it was
all thanks to Junior… the spawn of the Shy Guy!
Only a month before, the Foundation had
been subject to another bout of chaos,
although this one was much more subdued than
the explosive battle that would later sweep the
facility. Everyone was abuzz, researchers ignored
their work, and some security personnel even
abandoned their posts to see what all the fuss
was about: something was very wrong with SCP-096.
The creature was normally docile unless directly
observed. It spent the majority of its time just
pacing around its containment chamber or
staying hunched over in a fetal position,
crying to itself. In fact, it was so often
sobbing quietly and making all manner of
discontented noises that this became
known as its usual behavior. At first,
almost nobody had noticed that something was
even amiss, all seemed right with the miserable
monster… that is, until the screaming started.
It was a loud, shrieking sound that pierced the
eardrums of whoever heard it, then proceeded to
climb down their spine to bring a chill to their
bones, make their blood run icy cold, and cause
their skin to be littered with goosebumps. The
screeching, disturbing noise flooded out of
SCP-096’s cell, reverberating off every wall
and echoing down every corridor until not one
member of Foundation personnel could ignore it.
It was unlike anything they’d ever heard from
the creature before, this primal howling seemed
to put everyone who heard it on edge. Not just
because it was unfamiliar, but because everyone
uncannily seemed to know what the screams were
indicating: pain. Perhaps even the worst physical
pain that SCP-096 had ever felt. What if the
Shy Guy was dying? Something had to be done.
But therein lay a hurdle to clear first: how could
the Foundation help, even offer medical assistance
if needed, to a creature they couldn’t even safely
look at? What options are there for even getting
somebody close enough to examine the Shy Guy
without it killing them? They were limited,
but a crowd of the SCP Foundation’s best and
brightest researchers had already congregated
outside the containment chamber housing
SCP-096 after they’d heard its screams. Surely
between them, they could come up with an idea.
Hearing the Shy Guy continuing to howl in agony,
one researcher came forward and made a suggestion.
There was a device that another Foundation
researcher had developed, codenamed ‘SCRAMBLE’.
Resembling standard issue night vision goggles,
one Doctor Dan had created these ‘SCRAMBLE
Goggles’ to identify SCP-096’s face and
digitally alter it so that the wearer was
unable to see it. Essentially, it edited out
the Shy Guy’s face in real time, so that its
homicidal rage state couldn’t be activated.
The use of Doctor Dan’s SCRAMBLE Goggles had
previously led to a catastrophic incident that
claimed the lives of Mobile Task Force Tau-1,
also known as Big Brother. The SCRAMBLE devices
allowed the wearer’s brain to receive a single
nanosecond of SCP-096 unscrambled before the image
was altered by the goggles. So, needless to say,
since time was running out to help the creature,
and there were no other viable options for
doing so, the SCRAMBLE Goggles would need
some serious refinement – and fast!
Working as quickly as they could,
the gathered gaggle of researchers requisitioned
an old pair of SCRAMBLE Goggles and started
trying to improve them. Tirelessly tinkering
equipment specialists put their heads together
with computing engineers as they coded crazily,
all underscored by the continued screams of
SCP-096. Then, without warning or even any
hint of what had happened inside the cell,
the screaming suddenly stopped. Everyone outside
the containment chamber stopped for a second,
falling deathly silent. The goggles were almost
ready, but were they too late to save the Shy Guy?
The security personnel who had also gathered
in response to the sound all drew straws,
with the officer pulling the shortest being the
one tasked with venturing into the containment
chamber. He was handed the goggles and instructed
that they would blur his vision entirely for a few
seconds while the SCRAMBLE software had a chance
to work. Then, once the device had double, triple,
and quadruple-checked the results, the goggles
would activate fully and – in theory – work
the way Doctor Dan had originally intended.
Although, the track record of the SCRAMBLE
project meant the officer was hardly reassured as
he entered the dark, dingy containment chamber.
He couldn’t see a thing ahead of him, his vision
totally obscured as the goggles started running
the newly updated version of the SCRAMBLE
software. They were untested, so naturally,
the security officer’s nerves were at peak levels,
worried the device might fail, and any second,
his eyes would be greeted by the face of SCP-096.
He could tell the creature was still alive; there
was a low sound of panting breaths coming from the
far corner of the chamber, indicating it hadn’t
perished, although it might have been injured.
A sudden bleep from the SCRAMBLE Goggles
startled the officer – the device had made
its checks and was ready to activate. However,
an unexpected message blinked on
the heads-up display, that read:
“Warning: multiple subjects detected.”
Luckily enough, when the goggles activated,
the officer was relieved to see they had worked.
SCP-096’s face was a grainy, pixelated mess.
The creature showed little noticeable sign of any
injuries too and just seemed to be gently rocking
itself in the corner. But quickly, the reason –
and perhaps even the cause – of SCP-096’s earlier
screams soon became obvious: though nobody
had entered the containment cell before the
security officer, it seemed the Shy Guy wasn’t
alone. Standing at around a third of SCP-096’s
considerable height… was another Shy Guy.
Or, at least, another version, a creature almost
identical save for being shorter. It wobbled on
its elongated legs, like it wasn’t quite used to
standing upright. It kept both arms outstretched
towards SCP-096, almost as though it was reaching
out for a hug. But the Shy Guy stayed in the
corner, cowering away from the other creature.
Through his scramble goggles, the security
officer looked on in disbelief at the scene
before him. Somehow, completely unpredictably,
SCP-096 had spawned offspring. It’d had a baby.
There was a general air of disbelief
among the assembled staff outside the
containment chamber after the security officer
had relayed what had happened. Most were quick
to write it off as an impossibility; they’d
studied SCP-096 for a long time, and it had
been the only anomaly known to the Foundation
matching its own very particular description.
There had been no others sighted in the wild,
it didn’t seem to be part of a species, as far
as anyone knew. But other researchers refuted
this claim; given SCP-096’s ability to travel
at anomalous speeds and kill those that looked
at it, it stood to reason there could be others.
Maybe the Foundation wasn’t aware of a whole
species of Shy Guys because anyone who’d ever
seen one didn’t live long enough to report it.
Then someone mentioned that it wasn’t entirely
unprecedented for anomalies to have
offspring, either. A long while before,
SCP-049 – the infamous beak-masked Plague Doctor –
had laid an egg which had hatched into SCP-049-J,
a smaller version of himself composed of moss
and wads of tissue. Trying to apply logical
understanding to each and every anomaly
was a paradoxical exercise in futility:
all anomalies had their own rules, even rules
the Foundation had never observed before.
After a great deal of deliberation and additional
improvements of the SCRAMBLE technology,
a research team was sent into the containment
chamber to retrieve SCP-096’s progeny. The
parent creature was still shying away from its
creation, perhaps because it didn’t want to raise
it in a way that meant the child inherited its
deadly sense of self-consciousness. Then again,
maybe the Shy Guy was just afraid of what it
had unleashed on an unsuspecting Foundation…
Initial testing with the offspring creature
revealed it was perfectly healthy and seemingly
very much unlike its predecessor. Until any
official SCP Foundation designation number
could be assigned, the team examining it took to
calling it ‘SCP-096 Junior’ or shortened to simply
‘Junior’ for simplicity. Junior regarded
the Foundation scientists with curiosity,
intrigued by them as well as their surroundings,
picking up medical instruments before very
carefully placing them back where it found them,
treating every item it touched like they had
been made of the finest, most delicate glass.
One of the researchers likened its movements to
that of a lemur, or other similar primates, but
with the reserved, timid, and docile nature of
a well-domesticated pet.
That was at first.
Naturally, the SCP Foundation being the
organization that it is, there quickly became
an interest in whether Junior displayed the same
anomalous traits as SCP-096. Call it curiosity or
caution, they wanted to know if it would react the
same way when observed without the protection of
SCRAMBLE goggles. So, a test was devised, seating
a member of D Class personnel in the same room as
Junior, and tasked only with looking at the Shy
Guy’s spawn. Everyone gathered with bated breath,
the research team watching from an observation
deck, all of them wearing SCRAMBLE goggles to
blur Junior’s face. As a blindfolded D Class
was brought in and stood opposite Junior,
all of them already expected that the test
would unfold in a particular way. Which
made it all the more surprising when, as the D
Class’s blindfold was removed, nothing happened.
Junior regarded the convict with the same
general curiosity as it had for everyone else,
but beyond that, showed no change in behavior.
No wild crying, no murderous rage state. Nothing.
“Are we sure this is actually the Shy
Guy’s kid?” one of the researchers joked.
With the test concluded – and then repeated
a few extra times for good measure – Junior
was deemed a ‘Safe’ class anomaly. Much like
SCP-999 or Josie the Half-Cat, it was decided
that Junior be allowed to wander freely around
the facility. While initially a little unnerving
to some staff when they first saw him without
goggles, people quickly warmed to Junior. He was
like a small monkey from a safari park, although
with the added benefit of not stealing anyone’s
iPhone or wallet. At least, until shortly after.
Around nearly a month had passed since Junior’s
birth, and since then, an odd change had been
noted in SCP-096. The Shy Guy seemed calmer,
more at ease, and far less anxious. What’s more,
researchers discovered that, for the first time
ever… he could be observed. However, before they
could investigate further, all hell broke loose.
It started in the holding cells where D Class
were housed, initially written off as fights
between inmates that got a little too out of hand.
But soon, the Foundation’s own personnel started
to violently attack each other. It was sparked
at random, a state of animalistic rage that was
focused on their fellow staff members.
The people they worked with… the people
who saw them every day. And it didn’t stop.
Those working at the facility were seemingly
possessed by an inescapable urge to harm those
around them, as if punishing each other for just
looking at them. By the time a Mobile Task Force
was ordered to step in and diffuse the situation,
the scene they arrived to was one of utter chaos.
Further examination uncovered that those who had
seen Junior’s face had been exposed to an
anomalous effect. Looking at the creature
gave the observer the same rageful reaction to
being observed as SCP-096; they were compelled
to kill anyone who saw them. However, most
insidiously, this didn’t seem to take effect
instantly. In fact, those affected only entered
their collective rage state after everyone in the
facility had interacted with Junior at least once.
Almost like it’d been waiting to infect everyone.
While the remainder of the Foundation
mopped up the aftermath of the incident,
some theorized that SCP-096 had somehow expelled
all its self-consciousness, all its negative
traits into its progeny. This was supposedly
why the Shy Guy seemed much calmer, so much
so that it could even be observed. Whether Junior
simply couldn’t contain all SCP-096’s negativity,
or intentionally spread it to everyone around
it, is unknown. The only solution to get things
back to normal, was to put the Shy Guy’s
self-consciousness back where it came from.
Now go and check out “SCP-096 VS SCP-343”
and “SCP-096 VS SCP-106” for more!